maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors le grand truc de la semaine
évidemment la conférence de presse de
rené coty
prévue pour durer une heure et demie ça
a débordé d'une demi heure c'est un
signe c'est comme au foot quand on sait
pas marquer dans le temps réglementaire
on a les prolongations
alors rien que sur l'introduction ça a
duré 45 minutes il vous apprennent quoi
l'ena
après j'ai compris pourquoi ça a duré si
longtemps chirurgie une introduction ça
s'appelle une anesthésie et là on a eu
droit à la péridurale de l'esprit
malin hollande malin il a pris son temps
pour bien faire allumer dans le crâne
des journalistes le petit clignotant bon
et où le buffet yacouba champagne
la grande interrogation c'est évidemment
est-ce qu'il va réussir sa conférence de
presse ils sont courants les journaleux
que c'est lui qui a fixé la date et
qu'elle a eu six mois pour s'y préparer
je sais pas je rappelais que c'est un
énarque quand même la formation d'un
énarque j'ai vu ça coûte 160 8000 euros
par an ouais enfin si à ce tarif là tu
arrives à te faire déstabiliser par une
question denisot de là où c'est qu'il ya
un problème
alors l'opposition qui est très déçus
qui est très déçue évidemment vous vous
attendiez à quoi moi tu me lis quoi pour
vous faire plaisir moi président enfin
je le crois
ou du moins on me le dit mais je ne suis
pas sûr car je n'en ai ni les capacités
ni le talent ni le charisme mais je me
dois de dans l'affaissement
parce qu'un président de la république
c'est aussi un appel de sa relaxe ans et
c'est un homéopathe de la vie publique
un ostéopathe de la cohésion sociale
l'herboriste de l'industrie française
oui je le dis
parce que
oui
je me dois
pour persévérer dans la droite ligne de
ma nullité transcendantale
moi j'aimerais annoncer
que l'année prochaine nous allons sortir
du nucléaire mais aussi de l'hydraulique
de l'éolien du pétrole du compost et
même du solaire
moi je n'oublie pas mes engagements
je le dois aux français oui au droit de
vote aux étrangers mais par souci d'
équilibre car il faut apaiser je suis un
herboriste
je veux le supprimer au français comme
je veut interdire le mariage
hétérosexuel sauf entre cousins frères
et les personnes qui ont leurs quarante
annuités de cotisation
j'annonce aussi un nouveau paquet fiscal
qui portera la tv à 80 % la cg à 90 sur
l'impôt sur le revenu à 145 alors tout
ça je je en gros un en gros je suis bien
sûr je pars pas des velléités de
d'imitateur encore que canteloup doit
trembler mais avec cet humour
typiquement hollandais tu vois moi je
vois les sondages mais un sondage ne
fait pas le printemps encore moins les
galeries lafayette ou les samaritains
[Applaudissements]
et les journalistes tellement shooter
qui lui retrouver des accents
churchilliens
ah bon
il a dit quoi qu'il fallait stocker du
riz et de la farine en vue des futures
bombardement de la wehrmacht que va
sortir les soldats d'afghanistan les
concentrer sur la rive gauche du rhin si
seulement salut mon temps parce que ça
c'est moi sincèrement il commence à me
pomper les cheveux coiffés encore ce
qu'on devrait faire ce qu'on devrait pas
faire quoi c'est bon quoi nous on est là
comme des cons aplati devant cette
fascination pour l'industrie allemandes
savent à quoi ça va quoi quand même pas
recevoir des leçons tu sais plus quand
birkenstock qui sont fait défoncer par
des chars de fabrication soviétique
alors évidemment en face bon la droite
qui couine ouais ouais mais si hollande
a vu le courage de schroders savent à
quoi il a fallu six mois aux lampes pour
établir la tva quand sarko a mis dix ans
à piger que ça serait peut-être une idée
de supprimer les 35 heures
alors sarko il fait penser à un
parkinsonien épileptique l'illusion de
l'énergie dans la certitude du surplace
bref alors quelqu'un y est allé de son
couplet forcément je pense tout le monde
l'avait appelée selon françois bayrou
hollande a été à la hauteur de la
fonction
qu'est ce qui dit koné bayonne
l'entente de parler de la fonction
présidentielle on dirait un puceau qui a
pondu une thèse sur le point g
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment dans ce contexte c'est
normal que des artistes émergent
[Musique]
voilà on a trouvé le bob dylan de droite
le pussy riot monégasque s'il habite à
monaco le tips monaco grand repaire de
poètes la butte montmartre de la
méditerranée quand tu penses le gamin il
a 16 ans et 16 ans à 16 ans son problème
c'est le taux d'imposition
quoi parler de l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur un français a gagné au loto
on connaîtra pas son nom c'est pas con
il veut rester discret c'est pas le cas
de tout le monde exemple lagardère
arnaud et la télé belge a fait un
reportage sur huit ans tu le vois
dilapidé son pognon te dit que 75 % taux
d'imposition c'est un cadeau
je peux dire qu'à côté de la garder à
bernard tapie c'est mario monti
en revanche le type il a du flair quand
elle se trouvait une cagole en belgique
il faut y aller
ce cas le seul français qui va en
belgique pour s'appauvrir autant bernard
arnault ici exil pour payer moins
d'impôts lui c'est pour épouser une
belge pour diminuer ses bénéfices quoi
c'est pour la fille pas très futé pour
une croqueuse de diamants prendre un mec
qui n'a que cinquante ans
autant de patience ça s'appelle de
l'amour
ou alors arnauts et qui doit les
rassurer lui way t'inquiètes pas j'ai 90
ans mais j'ai toujours fait moins que
mon âge
parlant d'amour ça fait bizarre de vous
voir
sans humour sac ce n'est pas
eric naulleau sans humour c'est un peu
comme ces moules sont dieudonné on gagne
en compassion ce qu'on perd en rire
parlant de décès médiatique
l'international nous fournit
régulièrement son lot de macchabées
ouverture de la tombe d'arafat c'est
quelle folie ne jamais décongeler de la
viande halal
après le gigot de cette heure-là rafat
de deux enfants
dans tout ça pour voir s'il n'a pas été
farci au plutonium serait que l'
avantage s'ils en trouvent ce qu'ils
pourront toujours envoyer la dépouille
en iran pour qu'ils enrichissent leurs
bombes
je propose des choses voilà c'est ça
faut essayer
et d'ailleurs propos il ya une jolie
campagne d'affichage collectif de lutte
contre l'islamophobie qui a été refusé
par la ratp voit ici sont très mal pris
fin il fallait casser les codes rendre
se rendre sympathique quoi toi au fond
ce que les gens reprochent un peu aux
musulmans c'est de ne pas avoir assez
d'autodérision c'est ça moi j'avais une
idée de campagne quoi une belle campagne
qu'un mouton un barbu dans une baignoire
et le slogan entre nous c'est une
histoire de goût
[Applaudissements]
ouais ça sent la fatwa quoi
bien sûr faut peut-être terminée par
quelque chose d'un peu jolie et 7
borgioli je sais pas marionnettiste
accusé de pédophilie
les gens trouvent ça étonnant
franchement quand un type qui fait rire
des gosses en ayant un bras coincé dans
le cul d'un ours en peluche
[Applaudissements]
le glauque dans toute sa splendeur alors
évidemment et ce cas une bonne nouvelle
cette semaine
au bahia eu la journée de la gentillesse
je sais pas moi je comprends pas trop
journée de la gentillesse je pensais
qu'on avait déjà eu c'est la journée de
la femme c'est là on a donné un jour
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il mettait un peu de bleu